avec la rentrée parlementaire
mouvementée cette semaine à l'assemblée
nationale l'éducation est passée
inaperçue
il ya eu la sphère laurent lessard les
documents présumément volet de la cac et
les couteaux qui volent bas au parti
québécois
alors vous avez peut-être manqué ce qui
s'est dit sur un projet de loi très
attendu sur la réforme de la gouvernance
scolaire pour l'opposition et les
acteurs du milieu ça s'éternise vraiment
et c'est ici que j'arrive assez cru que
2500 pages de documents au ministère
l'éducation il y a eu quatre ministres
depuis 2014
d'abord yves bolduc qui a promis une
réforme en profondeur des commissions
scolaires mais il a dû quitter dans la
controverse
je démissionne en tant que ministre des
gammes entendu plus tard françois blais
devenu ministre a déposé le projet de
loi 86 de 60 pages visant à modifier la
loi sur l'instruction publique
ça a conduit au dépôt de 96 mémoire
totalisant plus de 2500 pages et pré
séance de consultation des commissions
scolaires serait une première je crois
auront des comptes à rendre
puis remaniement ministériel il y a eu
pierre moreau qui a dû abandonner parce
que malade on se retrouve avec sébastien
proulx a mis de côté le projet de loi de
blaye pour en proposer un autre moins
ambitieux qui exclut les enjeux de la
taxe et des élections scolaires
bien sûr il y aura encore des questions
il encore des réflexions il ya encore
des discussions on ne pensait pas qu'un
autre consultation était nécessaire
d'abord parce que vous avez déjà entendu
tout le monde
cette semaine il ya eu deux journées de
consultations sur ce nouveau projet doit
lé projet de loi 105 et quoi on retenir
et bien que les commissions scolaires
perte du pouvoir au profit du ministre
des parents et les directeurs d'école le
gouvernement espère pour faire adopter
son projet de loi d'ici la rentrée
scolaire l'an prochain et rappelons que
le gouvernement couillard a déjà
complété plus de la moitié son mandat